today on the matt walsh show joe biden
at his town hall last night proved once
again that he is a man
living in a fantasy world driven mad by
left-wing ideology the latest evidence
is his proposal that police officers
neutralize dangerous suspects simply by
shooting them in the leg
we'll talk about why this is an absurd
and unworkable idea also five headlines
including
the left doxing a woman because she
nodded during trump's town hall and in
our daily cancellation we will cancel
body shaming not the thing itself we're
gonna cancel the term body shaming
and all the panicking people do over
body shaming actually is not a big
problem
that's gonna be my point and all that
coming up first though let's talk about
helix sleep you know you need
you need a good night's sleep everybody
does uh sleep is a physical necessity i
don't know if you knew that
i know for me i've tended to struggle
with insomnia
until i figured out that i can sleep i
just have very specific sleep needs i'm
a high maintenance sleeper
a bit like the princess and the p or
something i relate very much to that
story
the great thing is that helix sleep can
meet anyone's sleep needs helix sleep
has a quiz that takes just two minutes
to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
if you like a mattress that's really
soft or firm if you sleep on your side
or your back your stomach
or you sleep really hot with helix
there's a specific
mattress for each and everybody's unique
taste just go to helixsleep.comwalsh
take their two minute quiz uh takes just
two minutes
it really is quick and they'll match you
to the customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
right now helix offers up to 200 off um
and free pillows with all mattress
orders for our listeners at helix sleep
dot com slash welsh
that's helix sleep dot com slash walls
for up to 200 off your mattress order go
there now helixsleep.comwalsh
all right well i saw a movie once you
know where um
the sheriff of a dusty old western town
thwarted a bank robbery by shooting the
gun out of the bad guy's hand
and then threw a rope around him and and
it lassoed him around the waist
all the bystanders applauded while the
sheriff tipped his cap
took the hog-tied crook off to jail
these sorts of moments are
enjoyable in films because they're fun
and simple and offer neat resolutions
and it can feel preferable to the real
world which sadly tends more towards
messiness and ambiguity
many people in our culture today
struggle to distinguish between the real
and the fantastical leading to among
other unfortunate consequences
unrealistic expectations and among
politicians
very stupid policy proposals police
critics
and would-be reformers have often
demonstrated this
failure of distinction by breezily
suggesting
that cops could avoid killing suspects
if only they behave more like hollywood
action heroes
what's the big deal just you know just
be a hollywood action hero
it's bad enough when this sort of
childishness emanates from internet
commenters and journalists but it
becomes a source of major concern
when coming from a guy who might be our
next president
so joe biden at his abc town hall last
night
answered a question about police reform
reform and and gave us some of this
complete nonsense listen
we can do this you can ban chokeholds
you can but
but beyond that you have to teach people
how to de-escalate circumstances
de-escalate so instead of anybody coming
at you the first thing you do is shoot
to kill
you shoot them in a leg there's ways you
have to do more background checks in
terms of whether or not
the person coming in passes certain
psychological tests and the last thing
i'll say and i'm sorry because it was
really
i think really really important is you
have to be in a position where
you are able to identify identify
the things that have to change and one
of the things has to change is
so many cops get called into
circumstances where somebody is mentally
off like what happened not long ago that
guy with the knife
that's why we have to provide within
police departments
psychologists and social workers to go
out with the cops on those calls those
some of those 9-1-1
calls to de-escalate the circumstance
to deal with talking them down instead
of anybody coming at you and first thing
you do is shoot to kill just shoot him
in a leg
biden said with all the seriousness and
credibility of a man
wondering whether plane crash fatalities
could be avoided by covering aircraft
and bubble wrap
biden of course is far from the first
person to put forward this just shoot
him in the leg thing anti-police
activists
often engage in similar silliness and
attempts have actually been made in new
york state
for example to to legally require cops
to aim for a suspect's
whims now that that law never went
through thank god
but it just shows you um it's
embarrassing this idea
for a number of obvious reasons first of
all legs are a narrow
fast moving part of the body unless
we're requiring
every police officer to be an expert
level marksman which
would be an even taller order when we
replace them all with social workers
which has been
suggested it's absurd to expect this
kind of accuracy during a high pressure
quickly evolving situation dr bill
lewinsky he's the executive director of
the force science institute
he's explained some of the science
behind this problem
and this is what he says quote hands and
arms can be the fastest moving body
parts for example an average suspect can
move his hand and forearm across his
body to a 90 degree angle
in 12 100 of a second he can move his
hand from his hip to his
to his shoulder height in 18 100 of a
second the average officer pulling the
trigger
as fast as he can on a glock one of the
fastest cycling semi-autos
requires a quarter of a second to
discharge each round
there is no way an officer can react
track shoot and reliably
hit a threatening suspect's forearm or a
weapon in a suspect's hand in the time
spans involved
he continues legs tend initially to move
slower than arms and and to maintain
more static positions
however areas of the lower trunk and
upper thigh are rich with vascularity
a suspect who's hit there can bleed out
in seconds if one of the major arteries
is severed
so again shooting just to wound may not
result
in just wounding on the other hand if an
officer manages to take a suspect's legs
out non-fatally
that still leaves the officer's hand the
offender's hands free to shoot
his ability to threaten lives has not
been necessarily stopped
so this touches on two of the other
major problems even if you successfully
hit the suspect's legs
you may sever his femoral artery the
main source of blood to his lower
extremities
causing him to bleed out rapidly anyway
if you don't hit the artery
well you'll have wounded him but you
haven't stopped him
depending on where you hit him and also
how much adrenaline or
or other foreign chemicals are coursing
through him the suspect will still be
able to run
walk certainly shoot at least now
let's apply this to actual real world
situations and
and and when we do that the feebleness
and incoherence of the just shoot him in
the leg proposal becomes clear take for
example
the shooting of ricardo munoz in
lancaster pennsylvania which prompted
rioting and protest
munoz came charging suddenly out of his
house wielding a large knife the officer
who was being attacked took him down
when he was mere feet away had the
officer
aimed for his leg and missed or grazed
him
he could have easily been stabbed to
death before he had a chance to get off
on this
another shot take the shooting of dion k
in washington dc
also a couple months ago he was shot
while running towards the officers
with his guns drawn this was all caught
on body cam again had they aimed for his
leg and missed
there'd be no time to fire again before
kay could get a shot off in the
officer's direction
had they shot and wounded him he still
would have been holding a gun
and perfectly capable and perhaps now
more likely to use it
so joe biden's suggested strategy would
have very likely gotten police officers
in both situations
killed as well as potentially dozens of
or hundreds more each year joe biden
is living in a fantasy world which will
become a very real and present danger
for law enforcement officers if any
attempt was made to bring his fantasies
to fruition
and speaking of fantasy worlds biden at
the town hall last night also
seemingly endorsed the insane notion of
transgender eight-year-olds here's that
moment listen
i'm the proud mom of two girls
eight and ten my youngest daughter is
transgender the trump administration has
attacked the rights of transgender
people
banning them from military service
weakening non-discrimination protections
and even removing the word transgender
from
some government websites how
will you as president reverse
this dangerous and discriminatory agenda
and ensure that the lives and rights of
lgbtq people are protected
under u.s law i will flat out just
change the law
every eliminate those executive orders
number one
you may recall i'm the guy who said i
was raised by a man
who i remember i was being dropped off
my my my dad was a
high school-educated well-read man who
was a really decent guy and i was being
dropped off to get an
application in the center of our city
wilmington delaware
the corporate capital of the world at
the time and these two men i'm
getting out to get a an application to
be a lifeguard in the african-american
community because it was a big swimming
pool complex
and uh and these two men well-dressed
leaned up and hugged one and kissed one
another
i'm getting out of the car at the light
and i turned to my dad my dad looked at
me said joey it's simple
they love each other the idea that an
eight-year-old child
or a ten-year-old child decides you know
i decided i want to be transgender
that's what i think i'd like to be make
my life a lot easier
there should be zero discrimination
now leaving aside that the story about
his dad and the gay men which he's told
before sounds completely made up
the issue is that biden is beholden to a
left-wing ideology
that stands a thwart reality hoping to
alter or abolish hard truths by
tearfully screaming at them
this is why he is dangerous
and absolutely cannot be given the power
that he seeks
let's get to our five headlines
well we've been talking about the
problems with big tech this week and so
i think now's uh
uh there's no better time to tell you
again
about expressvpn you know you know what
big tech and big government have in
common
they both want to silence any dissenting
voices into submission we have seen that
this week let's say you're a proud gun
owner
you want to talk on social media about
the right to bear arms well
chances are that your post will be
flagged by a content moderator and you
might end up
on some kind of government watch list to
fight back
against having your voice censored by
both big tech and big government i
recommend
expressvpn see the problem with big tech
is that
not only do they attempt to censor you
but they also track what you do online
what you're searching for videos you
watch everything you click so they're
going to learn everything about you
when i use expressvpn which i always use
expressvpn
they can't see my ip address at all my
identity is anonymous it's made
anonymous by a secure vpn server
plus expressvpn encrypts 100 of my
internet data for protection from
hackers and eavesdroppers i mean this is
your data your information no one else
has a right to it
and so you have to protect yourself um
expressvpn by far the best vpn that i've
tried
it's the vpn rated number one by cnet
wired countless other tech publications
you can look it up for yourself
um what that's what i love most about
expressvpn is that you know it's it's
it's highly recommended very effective
couldn't be easier to use
which is really important for me as as
you know a [ __ ]
so stop letting big tech and big
government censor and track you defend
your rights protect yourself
expressvpn.com wolves that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n.com
walsh to get three months free visit
expressvpn.com
walsh all right as mentioned
uh dueling town halls last night i i
thought trump performed
pretty well despite the extremely
aggressive moderating if we can call it
that by savannah guthrie on nbc
uh once again of course trump trump gets
the kind of hostile questioning
that joe biden has never ever received
and will never ever receive
but i thought trump was disciplined calm
focused
i thought it was good i would love to
see we talked about this yesterday i
would love to see this version of trump
and only this at least until election
day
that's what i would love to see i don't
expect it but
that's what i would like because i
thought it was it was uh very effective
and what that meant is the left had to
go elsewhere for controversy
because they couldn't get it from trump
and so they decided to focus instead on
a woman
sitting behind trump who was nodding
yes this was their focus a woman nodding
she was the target of leftist rage uh
and here she is you can see her there
nodding
look at her with her nodding how dare
you
who are you to nod who do you think you
are nodding
this is this is what you can go to
twitter and type in nodding
okay and search for it and you'll see
hundreds of tweets from people
condemning the nodding woman and trying
to dox her
find out who she is punish her for
nodding liz uh garbas for example liz
garvis a
a hollywood person i don't know some
kind of actress or something
uh she confessed to feeling quote a lot
of rage
about the woman nodding can you imagine
can you just you know i
i continue to be so impressed by the
ability
of many of these leftists to get angry
about stuff especially when i get angry
about things all the time
you know that's my thing i get a but
even i i'm left in in
in awe and admiration of their ability
to get angry because
they get angry about things that i
wouldn't even dream i couldn't even
conceive of being angry about them i
don't know how to do it
they need to teach me they've achieved a
level
of petty anger anger that is that is uh
you know makes me look
like an absolute novice in comparison so
i can't imagine watching a town hall
and just sitting there stewing look at
her nodding
stop nodding i can't i just
i wouldn't be able to do it i can't
understand it but this is what
rage i feel rage that the woman was
nodding
tom nichols um called for journalists to
find this woman
find out who she is and punish her he
didn't say punisher but that was
implied in fact tom nichols as you can
see
look at this he tweeted angrily about
the nodding woman
dozens of times he spent hours
without a hint of irony this was not
performance art
this was he was really this this is how
he decided to spend
his thursday night finding out who the
woman is who nodded at trump
and destroy her and then the media
started doing news articles about it
um until finally she was identified they
they succeeded in finding out who she
was and they identified her and
um and but you know the thing that set
them off obviously
is it's not just that a person was
nodding now if that was like
a white guy behind there nodding then i
think they probably would say nothing
about it
it's that she's a black woman how dare a
black woman
indicate any sort of agreement towards
trump
she's not allowed to it's not permitted
this
is the leftist mentality black people
are ours
women are ours latinos
racial minorities they belong to us
you belong to us is the message that the
left sends to people in those
demographics
uh they think they own them and if if if
they stray
if they get out of line if they
misbehave well the left is going to
punish them severely for it
this is the mentality it's sick it's
twisted it's deranged it's
it's crazy um
the way they react it's like it's like
they they really do react
like they have been personally betrayed
when a black person black woman
especially because now you have the
intersection you got two
two intersectional points here black
woman um
indicates it all that that she might not
be a leftist
they react as though they have been
personally stabbed in the back
and betrayed by like that person owes
them
something and they are not getting what
they are owed
number two how about some positive news
for a change um honestly this news
made me very happy just wonderful stuff
here from the daily wire it says
enrollment rates have declined for
undergraduate students at colleges and
universities across the united states
and much of it can be attributed to
fewer freshmen choosing to attend
according to a new study released on
thursday figures from the national
student clearinghouse research
center center show that first-year
students have enrolled in colleges at a
16 percent lower rate
than first years in 2019. this group of
students account for 69 percent of the
total decline
in the national undergraduate enrollment
rate a figure that currently stands at
a four percent decline the data also
shows that community colleges have been
particularly affected by the decline
experiencing roughly a 23 percent drop
in
enrollment rates um doug shapiro
executive director of the center
uh of uh what center some center i just
talked about oh the national student
clearinghouse
told the new york times in an interview
that community college enrollment during
the great recession actually increased
and called the declining rate 2020
enrollment data staggering
i fear that many of those students will
never go back well look
i got nothing against community college
so uh this is uh
i think community college has a real
role so this is nothing against them
but as far as the four-year universities
experiencing this drop
we can only pray it continues and uh and
that many of them are bankrupted
and destroyed that's my dream scenario
dozens and dozens of these god forsaken
institutions
boarded up abandoned and we can all
gather and hold hands in a circle around
the abandoned buildings dancing
dancing the night away that's that is my
that is my fantasy um
and why would i feel that way about them
well you know no reason
except that these institutions are
financially bankrupting generations of
americans
um forcing them not forcing them but
duping them
into paying for the privilege of being
brainwashed
in exchange for being made poor and in
debt
they'll also make you confused and
deluded that's the deal and so
yeah um yeah i i would uh
i'm a big fan of the idea of of them
suffering
enormous financial consequences for that
now number three let's move on to this
from the daily wire here's a story to
prove my point about the last thing we
just talked about
says the university of minnesota's
school of social work and continuing
education series recently hosted what
they called
a special webinar series that was titled
quote
deconstructing and decentralizing
whiteness in practice
a three-part series in which a lecture
titled
recovery from white conditioning taught
white people how to use a 12-step
program similar to alcoholics anonymous
to recover and reclaim our full humanity
okay um i can't even read any more of
this so it's a 12-step program to
overcome
being white i know we're so used to this
by now that we're numb to it but
let's really focus on the fact that they
are treating whiteness
like a literal disease like a sickness
and they're doing this while claiming
that there's no racism against white
people
no there's no racism against white
people you diseased demons
that's the message number four stevie
nicks of fleetwood mac
enjoying a bit of a career resurgence
because of that video of the guy
skateboarding and drinking juice
that's all it takes these days has now
come out and credited her career success
with her decision to murder her unborn
child
in a recent interview she says quote
abortion rights that was really my
generation's fight if president trump
wins this election
and puts the judge in he wants she will
absolutely outlaw it
and push women back into back alley
abortions
side note by the way the supreme court
is not going to be outlawing abortion if
they
overturn roe v wade then it goes to the
states and it will still remain legal in
many states
you know california new york but many of
the most popular states will remain
legal in
uh anyway if i had uh if i had not had
that abortion i'm pretty sure that there
would have been
no fleetwood mac perish the thought
there's just no way that i could have
had a child then working as hard as i
worked constantly
and there were a lot of drugs i was
doing a lot of drugs
i would have had to walk away and i knew
that the music we were going to bring to
the world
was going to heal so many people's
hearts and make people happy
and i thought you know what that's
really important there's not another
band in the world that has two lead
women singers two lead women writers
that was my world's mission
you know i have to say there are no good
reasons to kill a child
ever period but this reason
that you had to kill a child in order to
ensure that the world is not deprived of
fleetwood mac
this has to be perhaps at the top of the
list of the really bad reasons
she's saying she killed her child so she
could do drugs and make money
i'm sorry work hard and i like how she
lumps in
you know i was working so hard back then
uh and doing a lot of drugs
working hard and doing drugs somehow to
me those seem like mutually exclusive
pursuits don't they either you're at a
point your life or you're doing a lot of
drugs
or you're at a point where you're
working hard it doesn't seem likely that
you're doing both
but regardless um that's why she killed
her child
how do you think she's feeling about
that decision now
i know how she pretends to feel but how
does she actually feel she's 72 years
old
childless alone not married has no
children
plenty of money sure and some hit
records all of which are decades old
does the money keep her company on those
long cold
nights will the song she she's already
sung a million times
give her comfort as she lives out her
final years on this earth
it's just impossible to believe that a
woman at this stage of life
would still feel great about killing the
only child she ever had
for for for success that's now gone and
fame that has faded
and fun times that are all mostly in the
past now it's just there's no way
you are alone
with your past success being your only
legacy
i mean who cares about fleetwood mac who
cares about fleetwood mac now
who's going to care about fleetwood mac
50 years from now
i don't know about you but but i i know
how she feels about it
i would trade fleetwood mac's music in a
heartbeat for her child
if i could number five dr fauci now says
that we may have to bite the bullet this
year
and um sacrifice thanksgiving this is
him talking about that listen
of course that's such a sacred part of
american
tradition the family gathering around
thanksgiving but
that is a risk you may have to bite the
bullet and sacrifice that social
gathering
unless you're pretty certain that the
people
that you're dealing with are not
infected okay in fairness you did have
that qualifier there he says can't
cancel thanksgiving unless you're sure
nobody is sick
but there's always that vagueness to it
right uh and then it comes and
then and then and then eventually it's
no no it's banned never mind so
that's the way it's always worked like
15 minutes or 15 minutes
might as well they might as well said 50
15 days to slow the spread
they said hey it's only 15 days you know
give or take this is fifty maybe fifteen
days
oh but dr fatty what happens after
fifteen days well you know we'll see
we'll see i it you know it's it could be
done at 15 days who knows
i know this tactic because i use it with
my kids
and they're finally starting to catch on
that if they ask me for something and i
give them the
maybe we'll see sure i mean maybe yeah
maybe
and then i especially if i add the
qualifier uh maybe yeah
you know it's if there's time at the end
of the day
uh to get ice cream well we we might do
that sure maybe
that they've realized that that's just a
no
that is a no in gestation that is no in
its embryonic
phase um and that's uh that's what we're
getting from factory
but in this case the good thing is you
know that
i don't personally give a damn about
fauci's opinion of my thanksgiving plans
it makes no difference to me i'm not
canceling thanksgiving i'm going to have
thanksgiving it's my favorite holiday
because there and i'll tell you why it's
my favorite very simple lots of food
no presents i don't have to give
presents i don't have to receive them
which is also a great burden for me
because i have to pretend that i like it
all the presents i get
um it just we get rid of all that and
just get right to the food
that's all i care about these days when
you're a child holidays are about
presents when you're an adult it's
really just about the food that's
who cares about the present um so it's
my favorite holiday i'm not gonna be
canceling it
and uh we're gonna be having
thanksgiving we will not be wearing
masks
and we will not be practicing social
distancing uh
and we're just gonna be you know we're
gonna be normal people having a
thanksgiving celebration
and but you know in fact i'm not gonna
be forcing anyone to attend that's the
other good thing so
i i was i'm not gonna go and abduct
anybody off the street
and and make them sit at my table uh you
know under threat of under threat of
murder
with a gun pointed to their head and
stuff cranberry sauce down their throat
i'm not gonna do that
we will hold off on that aspect of our
normal tradition this year
which means that anyone who's at
thanksgiving with me
they chose to be there they chose to
take on the risk which i think is
is is not a very enormous risk but they
chose to take on that risk for the sake
of turkey and gravy and i
think it is a gamble worth taking
personally
um all right let's go right to our
daily cancellation today for our daily
cancellation we're going to cancel body
shaming not the thing itself
not the shaming but rather the focus on
it the hysteria over it
the claims made about it that's what
we're canceling
and just for example we'll start we'll
start with this um you know
and this year you know it's been a
chaotic parade of major news stories one
after the other
perhaps none have been quite as
significant though as the news that made
headlines across the media landscape
this week
you no doubt have probably already heard
pop singer billy eilish
was body shamed this is a big deal
you're supposed to care about this sort
of thing though nobody
is sure exactly why trumpet blast
resounded alerting the whole internet to
the incident which
quickly became a national crisis fox
news says billy eilish claps back at
body shamers
yahoo reports billy eilish responds to
body shamers
msn tells us billy eilish body shaming
video goes viral as singer responds to
trolls
the independent l e t cosmopolitan other
publications had their own reports
buzzfeed as always
published the definitive essay on the
topic in a post titled
grown ass adults please stop body
shaming billy eilish
that article written by pulitzer
candidate ryan shockett
informs us that a recent photo of the
singer walking down the street wearing a
tank top
and shorts and sandals with socks set
off a wave of critiques commentary and
discussion
now by the way as an avid sock and
sandal wearer myself
unapologetically so i would hope that
the photo would if anything
um help to normalize the sock and sandal
community
but instead of discussing the advantages
of footwear that allows you to probably
show off your favorite socks instead of
hiding them inside dreary and boring
shoes
it seems that the discussion in this
case took a negative turn
the body shamers were out in force a
whole wave of them
part of the body shaming epidemic as it
has been called
all of them set on ruthlessly mocking
and belittling billy eilish one of the
body shaming tweets from an anonymous
user said
in 10 months billy eilish has developed
a mid-30s wine mom
body another body shamer said
wait there wasn't another one that was
pretty much it there was precisely
one negative comment from some guy in
england
who goes by the handle game snosh and
many thousands of comments from people
mercilessly scolding him for his rude
behavior
while heaping compliments and accolades
on eilish now i have not counted all of
them but i would say
i would guess that there's probably a
100 000 to one ratio
of positive to negative comments and
that's probably a significant
understatement
also uh the people saying nice things
include powerful media platforms
fellow celebrities the people saying
mean things include
gamesnosh though in fairness if i
scoured twitter i'm sure i could
probably
find up to a dozen you know accounts
with anime avatars also insulting
heilish
in hopes of leeching some of the
attention from the dastardly gangster
but all told i don't think there's a
real problem here
lots and lots of people are saying very
nice things about a woman who walked
down the street
wearing shorts one dude said not nice
things this is not exactly pearl harbor
in terms of national significance
true eilish has been targeted by shamers
before or so i'm told
she's spoken out about the body shaming
and issued many eloquent clapbacks over
the years but again to look at her
instagram account or
music videos on youtube reveal a very
near unanimous agreement that eilish is
beautiful
amazing brilliant she also won six
grammy awards this year which
should serve i would think as a nice
self-esteem boost but even with millions
of adoring fans and
legions of of internet warriors ready to
leap into action to rip anyone to shreds
should they utter the mildest insult
about her looks music or anything else
we're still told that there's a real
problem even a newsworthy problem
of billy eilish being body shamed
it's not just billy eilish to hear the
media tell it you would think that we
live in a culture
utterly beset by body shaming great
effort is made to denounce body shaming
counteract body shaming
raise awareness about body shaming
eradicate body shaming
and the body shaming problem has
attracted such intense focus that it's
even been broken down
into sub categories we've gotten very
specific with it there's the infamous
fat shaming the slightly less infamous
skinny shaming plus there's tall shaming
short shaming hair
shaming bald shaming skin shaming teeth
shaming foot shaming hand shaming breath
shaming
butt shaming and we could continue down
the list of of body parts all of which
have their own dedicated shamers and
also their own dedicated anti-shamers
but at least we could say the shaming is
relegated to external features so far
i'm not aware of any
spleen shamers or kidney shamers
yet despite the exorbitant attention
paid to the problem
i doubt that people are more likely to
make mean comments about your body today
than at any other point in history in
fact it seems quite certain that body
shaming today
is much less common than it once was
after all there was a time when you
could walk outside you know you put on
your sunday's best
and head into town to laugh at obese
people and hairy women
at an event that was literally called a
freak show
we may have our own ways of gawking at
strange physical specimens these days
but we usually do it through
through reality tv and usually it
assumes an ostensibly inspirational or
medical tone
my 600 pound life on tlc for example is
a show about extremely obese people
but it sells itself as an opportunity to
follow participants as we document their
life-saving journey
this is a kinder and gentler approach to
the spectacle for
at least in this sense a kinder and
gentler age
and it's probably the best we can hope
for from a fallen species such as
ourselves
now i'm not saying that nobody is ever
shamed for the way they look
i know i i know they are i am i read my
youtube comments on occasion
you bastards but if a person
is subjected to a greater quantity of
mean comments today
it's only because we interact with so
many more people
and we put ourselves in front of large
audiences all the time
as part of living our half human half
cyborg
lives in cyberspace there's always going
to be
small petty jerks who love snickering
anonymously from the sidelines if given
the opportunity
but all the attention they're given only
makes a troll molehill into a mountain
most people whether on the internet or
in three-dimensional space
are not inclined to make any comments
about your physical looks
and most who are inclined will say nice
things and if you are ever subjected to
a genuinely vicious attack
you can always post about it on facebook
and get thousands of people lining up to
assuage your damaged ego and
donate generously to your gofundme
campaign
what we should consider is that maybe
the real epidemic when it comes to body
shaming
and bullying generally is that we are so
unable to
deal with it the interesting question is
not
why are all these people saying mean
things but rather
why are all these people incapable of
handling the mean things that are said
to them
we could run around till our faces turn
blue demanding that everybody see
themselves as beautiful just the way
they are but at a certain point
a person has to learn to function in the
world without a constant iv
drip of positive emotional reinforcement
if a bit of taunting from the internet
peanut gallery causes you to plunge into
despair
you probably have issues which the
peanut gallery didn't cause
and which would still exist even if they
all agreed that you're the most
gorgeous specimen in the whole world
there isn't much evidence that people
are any meaner now than they've ever
been at any other point in history
but there is a fair amount of evidence
that we're far more vulnerable
and dependent upon affirmation than at
any other point in history
you know some of the reason for this
shift isn't hard to decipher social
media
intentionally breeds this kind of
fragility and mass codependence
many billions of dollars have been spent
on technology designed
precisely to give you this fragile
emotional complex and many more billions
have been made because of it
now it also should be stated that some
of the things we call body shaming
can come from a place of genuine sincere
concern on the part of the alleged
shamer
you know calling somebody fat and ugly
or stupid is clearly an insult but
these days we're so determined to
eradicate body shaming that even a
medically
accurate and sound statement like
obesity is unhealthy or
you know you shouldn't be proud of being
morbidly overweight
even that is denounced as shaming billy
eilish is obviously not obese so this
doesn't apply in her case but we have
run so far the other end of the shaming
extreme
but now we tell people to embrace and
celebrate aspects of their physical
appearance
that they can change and will kill them
if they don't
so in the end body shaming is not all
it's cracked up to be
if you really feel shame about your body
because some
anonymous troll teased you the problem
is less the troll
and more the fact that you care what the
troll thinks in the first place that you
are in fact
desperately in need of affirmation from
that troll
and his withholding of it causes you to
spiral
into emotional crisis that is the
problem
in a sense you are the problem focus on
that
until then you're canceled
that was my inspirational talk for the
day i hope you feel better
at the end of it um and we will leave it
there
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening have a great weekend godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
dailywire2020
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton